hold on
oh no
what's the next one Sunday morning I
think
some pictures
he took a picture of me
uh-huh
why
I'm a photographer
you didn't ask permission I never asked
permission
why not
because I work in trenches battlefields
and combat zones
really
uh-huh
you mean you're a war photographer
mostly
Sometimes I cover sporting events my
name is Augie Steinbeck mm-hmm
what are you gonna do with that
picture huh well
if it's any good I guess I'll try to
sell it to a magazine now that you
mention it Mitch Campbell eating a
waffle
make me a print first to approve
uh-huh
this is Dinah
this is a Woodrow I have a question have
you ever been shot with bullets have I
ever been
once or twice just grazed he got
shrapnels in the back of the head too
shower
I don't say I forgive you yet by the way
welcome from the United States military
science research and experimentation
division in conjunction with the Larkins
Foundation We Salute You
[Applause]
each year we celebrate asteroid day
commemorating September 23 3007 BC when
the Arid Plains meteorite made Earth
impact
the itinerary for this three-day
celebration includes a tour of the newly
refurbished Observatory with Dr
hickenburger staff
a picnic supper of Chilean frankfurters
with evening fireworks display
the viewing of the astronomical ellipses
at its peak just before midnight tonight
and finally the awarding of the annual
Hickenlooper scholarship after Monday's
banquet lunch
now I'll start by presenting the
commemorative medals but first I'll do
my speech first which you'll also
receive in a folio Edition is souvenir
chapter one
I walked to school 18 miles each morning
milk the goats pluck the chicken's plate
hooky caught fireflies went skinny
dipping in the watering holes at my
prayers every night and got whipped with
a maple switch twice a week that was
life
[Music]
chapter 2 my father went off to fight in
the war to end all wars it didn't and
what was left of him came back in a pine
box with a flag on top end of chapter
two
next I went to Officer school in 20
years passed at the speed of a dream a
wife a son a daughter a poodle
chapter 3 Another War arms and legs
blown off like popcorn eyeballs gouged
out figuratively and literally the men
put on shows under the palm fronds
dressed as women in hula skirts that was
life
in the meantime somebody else's story a
man thinks up a number divided by a
trillion plugs it into the square root
of the circumference of the earth
multiplied by the speed of a splitting
atom and voila progress I'm not a
scientist you are end of chapter three
Junior star gazers and Space Cadets we
watched transfixed as you enter into
Uncharted territories of the brains and
spirit
if you wanted to live a nice quiet
peaceful life
with the wrong time to get born
[Music]
be notified you are each the guardian of
your own safety maintain alert caution
throughout the following demonstrations
to Ricky Cho for his work in the field
of aeronautical induction the collapsing
star ribbon of success to Clifford
Kellogg for his work in the study of
particle disintegration
the black hole Badge of Triumph to Dina
Campbell fueled by Cosmic radiation
instead of sunlight for a work in the
area of Botanical acceleration
unfortunately makes all vegetables toxic
the red giant sash of Honor
to Shelley Borden for her work in the
realm of mineral fabrication I
synthesized an extraterrestrial element
it's going to be added to the periodic
table next year the distant nebula
Laurel crown
to Woodrow steenbeck
for his work in the sphere of
astronomical imaging
it may have applications in the
development of interstellar advertising
the white dwarf medal of achievement
our tour ends here thank you for your
attention and thank you to the Larkins
foundation for their generous funding
what do those pulses indicate what oh
the beeps and blips we don't know
indecipherable radio emissions from
outer space probably a red herring does
it change ever not to my knowledge
it's a date Maybe
it's a date on the galactic calendar
Mary we think it's a date on the
galactic calendar wow is it always today